e aí ela não quis explicar tudo bom
vocês
olha está sem boné que eu cortei o
cabelo aleluia não temos é que eu não
gosto de cortar o cabelo só pela mistura
que existe na terra a pessoa tem um
cabelo ruim mas não gosta de cortar o
cabelo sou eu hoje eu criei coragem para
ir lá e com o teu cabelo pessoal tá
pensando que aqui em projetos em tesoura
nos nove jogos
roy que essa moto no curro aparelho deus
é incrível é incrível o pessoal pensando
deve passar ninguém nessa rua e não
passa mas na hora que eu dou play nessa
câmera que passa jumento passa moto
passa carro passa avião é que há pouco
que o aeroporto é aqui do lado não sei
vou peitar a volta às aulas é vocês se
lascar [ __ ] moça do [ __ ] já fala em
pagar de volta aqui rapariga o povo
estranho quando perde assim um dia você
vai fazer faculdade não quero fazer
faculdade talvez um dia eu faço quando
tiver mais estabilizado assim o que
fazer cinema fazer publicidade alguma
coisa do tipo mas não quero agora é que
a realidade não gosto de estudar não
gosto de escola não gosto e não gosto é
verdade que eu passei muito tempo da
minha vida na escola e eu acabei que eu
peguei um olho eo professor ele insiste
em falar que a gente vai precisar da
matemática na nossa vida na lógica a
gente precisa saber de matemática nossas
vidas mas eu não preciso saber onde é
que está o x eu fiquei um tanto onde
desenvolve a xaxis em equação opinião
foi preencher um formulário é pular ea
mulher falou assim eu queria só você
marcar o fim da horta no faial x perto
de mim não aparenta um raio que o
professor sempre gosta de falar que a
gente vai precisar um dia daquele tipo
de equação dizendo que a gente vai
melhorar as nossas contas do dia a dia a
é né
eu também sei uma coisa que melhore
minhas contas do dia a dia calculadora
[ __ ] na verdade que mais me incomoda na
volta às aulas são às aulas porque na
verdade é muito o colégio é bom ser ver
os amigos de novo se fazer palhaçada
dessas coisas é bom né e na hora que o
professor de física na sala unidade onde
estão na hora eu sei eu sei que o
professor e educador
na sala de aula eu sei que o professor
levou anos para se formar para poder dar
um sim de qualidade que os alunos mas eu
tenho muita raiva e alguns professores
que têm aquela autoritária idade
na hora da aula sabe tipo o professor de
matemática para um dvd-vídeo questão
aula de história passou de kim
radiografia
a geografia já era tão bom que a gente
chamar geografia de estudos sociais
história geografia passando de 17
questão a de inglês deve passar de 25
chega uma hora que você fica
sobrecarregado tarefa você sempre deixam
para depois acaba esquecendo chega na
hora da aula o professor ruim é só o
cadê a sua tarefa que fala pouco pessoa
aqui pô professor tal passou vinte
questão professor tal passou 15 ou
passou 31 deu por fazer a sua a ele vem
com aquela frase irônica de professor
isso não é desculpa para não ter feito
de ver unidas e aí a hora que ele comece
a diminuir na sala de aula na feira os
teus colegas poderia ter deixar de
assistir pra fazer o dever a palheta
largada aquela escolha de vídeo do
youtube desviado poderia ter ido dormir
um pouquinho mais tarde não podia não zé
roberto sabe que eu tenho e nem dispor
que até que eles podem falar isso a
raiva que eu tenho quando a gente faz
prova que eles passam um mês em corrigir
essa foi a quarta pessoa vai entregar a
prova não e falar eu tenho que corrigir
a prova do terceiro a encanta corrigir a
prova do 3º b e corre a prova do
primeiro ano em corrigir a prova do 2º
ano aí nessa hora não pode chegar para
ele falar assim poderia ter dormido
pouco mais tarde porque não poderia
deixar de assistir aqueles vídeos no
youtube enviado poderia ter deixado
assistiu do big brother brasil e
corrigir as provas não podia não pôde
não aparelho mas fora isso a escola é
até um lugar legal não se faz muita
amizade a maioria dos seus amigos sai de
lá da escola com você para que alguns
vão para outros lugares da terra do
inferno mesmo que não seja dentro da
sala de aula na escola já tem muita
coisa que é isso aí pessoal esse que foi
um vídeo de hoje muito obrigado por você
ter assistido eu amo muito vocês mas é
obrigado você tem assistido é pessoal é
eu tinha visto que alguém tinha votado
em mim o concurso eu não sabia que
estava nesse concurso e agora eu quero
ir para esse concurso o link é este que
a descrição do vídeo primeiro é só você
clicar lá se você tiver twitter
você vai twittar é porque eu devo ganhar
esse prêmio
só isso é fácil acho que nem nada mas é
bom saber que você me apoiar alguma
coisa então vota lá se quiser
quer ficar por dentro de quanto tem de
novo fazer perguntas quando tiver um
vídeo novo é só você me seguir no
twitter que esse aqui e assim lá no
facebook se você não está inscrito neste
canal por favor sim se você não está
escrito esse canal você não sabe quanto
tempo de lobo é só clicar em
inscrever-se toda vez que sair quanto
você vai saber outra coisa importante se
você está assistindo esse vídeo pelo
facebook faça o favor de curtir que
quando você curte aí fulano vai ver a
fulano curtiu tal liddicoat aqui
compartilha marcando seu amigo esse laço
na escola comente aqui embaixo que você
acha de mais estranho tem mais raiva na
escola
muito obrigado e valeu